this video is brought to you by Wix
what's up guys
Jared again today we're finally
addressing a movie that has plagued our
comment section for what seems like
forever Donnie Darko now over the years
we've tried to tackle this head
scratching movie from almost every angle
we wrote a full script for earthling
cinema and another for a philosophy of
video but nothing ever panned out Donnie
Darko became a Sisyphean task we did the
research wrote the scripts to only
delete it all and move on but we
couldn't just give up this movie is a
cultural phenomenon one might even say
it inspired a whole generation to
appreciate independent film so it
behooves us to ask why did this film
resonate on the level that it did well
with the help of our new format
half-baked we think we can finally lay
this movie to rest so join me on this
slightly confusing literal journey
through time in this wisecrack
half-baked edition on Donnie Darko and
yeah the film's almost 20 years old but
hey spoilers ahead well before we get
started want to give a shout out to our
sponsors over at Wix right now you can
build your own professional web site for
free using their easy-to-use templates
last year I created a website for my
voice-over work so let me show you how I
did it I was creating a website for
myself and I wanted well not a business
not a blog I wanted a there we go
portfolio and CV and lucky for me Wix
already had template options for
anything you might need so of course I
chose voiceover artists so I just picked
a design template and followed their
instructions and now I've got a
professional looking site to send to
potential clients so if you want to step
up your game in the new year and create
your own website for free go to Wix comm
slash wisecrack or click the link in the
description to get started and now on
with the show first a quick recap Donnie
Darko takes place in 1988 Middlesex
Virginia a quiet upper-class summer
Donnie a high schooler is woken up by a
mysterious voice in the middle of the
night he wanders halfway across town and
learns this
[Music]
more whirring still when Donny stumbles
back home the next morning he finds it
ruined a jet engine crashed right
through his bedroom
Donny then spends the rest of the month
stumbling through some weird that
culminates in him saving the world by
going back in time he does this by well
we don't know but it involves listening
to this terrifying imaginary bunny Frank
did Frank tell you to do these they
saved my life and to a B in following
this supposed master plan
Donny does some crazy stuff he floods
his school burns down a pedophiles house
and takes his girlfriend Gretchen on a
Halloween date to an old woman's cellar
door but she goes down and Gretchen is
accidentally run over leaving Donny to
face doomsday alone when the fated day
arrives a wormhole opens up over Donny's
house and he watches from afar with
Gretchen's body what happens next well
time travel I guess Donny wakes up in
his bed 28 days earlier laughing because
he succeeded in going back in time in
doing so he saved Gretchen from her
automobile fated death and his family
who was on a plane going through that
wormhole then right on cue the jet
engine comes crashing down and kills
Dunn meanwhile the rest of our cast is
left feeling oddly connected as if
somehow vaguely aware of Donny's
sacrifice roll credits
now if the details left you scratching
your head don't worry you're not alone
Donny Darko is such a rapid-fire
succession of ideas and beams that it
can be a bit difficult to analyze now is
there a grand philosophy to the film
well here's what we came up with idea 1
world lines and Graham Greene early on
the film draws parallels between Donny's
journey and that of the destructors a
short story by Graham Greene taught in
Donny's English class in the story a
gang of London Street kids set their
hearts on destroying an old man's home
down to the very last break they start
by dismantling the interior then destroy
all the valuables and plug the
foundation before finally they bring the
walls themselves down surprisingly
though the
boys aren't doing this out of hate as
Donnie explains well they say right when
they flood the house and they tear it to
shreds that like destruction is a form
of creation so the fact that they burn
the money is ironic they just want to
see what happens when they tear the
world apart I'm gonna change things
this idea of destruction as an act of
creation is critical to understanding
Donny's journey after all Frank's master
plan pretty much amounts to a bunch of
senseless destruction when it's all said
and done
Donny floods to school burns down a home
and gets at least two people killed but
the film also heavily implies that
everything Donnie did was absolutely
necessary to go back in time and save
the world
now it's not exactly clear how I mean in
the new universe that pedophile is still
a large but the director's cut leads us
to believe that he was using destruction
to create the conditions upon which the
wormhole would appear it does this by
first telling us the story of T the
short stories protagonist whose plan
seemed faded It was as though this plan
had been with him all his life
pondered through the seasons now in his
15th year crystallized with the pain of
puberty then it draws a parallel between
T and Donnie by showing us this surreal
moment of the film when we're yeah as
Donnie later figures out with the help
of his science teacher these weird
bubble path things were actually a
visualization of the future H vessel
travels along vector through space-time
center like a sphere
I beg your pardon like like a spear that
that comes out of your chest sure and
this is where the film draws on actual
science these Spears as Donnie calls
them are a real concept in physics as
physicist philosopher combo David
Deutsch and Michael Lockwood explain
your life forms a kind of
four-dimensional worm in space-time the
tip of the worms
tail corresponds to the event of your
birth and the front of its head to the
event of your death an object seen at
any one instance is a three-dimensional
cross-section of this long thin
intricately curved worm the line along
which the worm lies is called the
objects worldwide by being able to see
his world line meaning his own position
in the past present and future Donnie
knows what he needs to do to make the
time machine of course you might be
wondering if Donnie being able to see
his future is a logical contradiction
after all if the future is written
doesn't that mean we have no free will
and props to the film again it gives a
shout-out to this idea well you're
contradicting yourself Donnie if we were
able to see our destinies manifest
themselves visually then we would be
given a choice to betray our chosen
destinies and the mere fact that this
this choice exists would make all
preformed destiny come to an end now
it's hard to say that Donnie is
contradicting himself when he says that
knowing the future is compatible with
free will as philosopher David Lewis
explains in his groundbreaking paper the
paradoxes of time travel our definition
of possible changes based on how
complete our set of facts is for example
not knowing my future self it's possible
that I could mount a bid for president
in 2024 but let's say I did know the
future and that Bower 2024 never
happened because I'd rather watch movies
and play read dead well knowing this
fact about my future I would be right in
saying it's not possible I'd run for
president now importantly for Lewis
though my knowledge of the future
wouldn't limit my free will in the
present just because I know I'm more
likely to play video games than
the president doesn't mean the universe
would cosmically conspire to stop me if
I tried
there won't be glitches in the matrix if
I tried him out to bid in the end it's
not that future me couldn't run for
president
it's that present me knows that future
me doesn't run for president because
there's just too many legendary animals
to find all that being said though does
the film explore the conflict between
free will time travel and foreknowledge
well not really and that's why we
couldn't really make a definitive thesis
in our prior attempts honestly it feels
like the film is all the building blocks
for some super deep philosophical
insight but never quite puts them
together instead Donnie talks about
changing his world line like this now if
you travel within God's channel
God's channel while there are a boatload
of god-fearing scientists by citing a
transcendental all-powerful being in the
argument the film changes the topic from
the physical to the mystical and sure on
the surface this comment might not make
a whole lot of sense but the film is
actually tapping into something much
deeper here idea to quantum physics and
the director's cut now God might seem
like a weird idea for Donnie to toss
around especially considering that much
of the film is a not-so-subtle critique
of upper-class conservatism in their
sanctimony but that all depends on which
version you watched the theatrical
release or the director's cut while the
theatrical cut is a good deal shorter it
also omits for better or worse a lot of
writer director Richard Kelly's
world-building particularly in the
director's cut you get excerpts like
this from Roberto sparrows book the
philosophy of time travel yeah so to
summarize Donny's story takes place in a
tangent universe which is about to blow
that is unless Donnie stops it in 28
days in setting up Donnie as the messiah
or living receiver in the film's lingo
the movie gives him some weird powers
and some even weirder eyes Donnie then
saves the world returning the tangent
universe to the primary one while that
might all seem like some random stuff
that Kelly just made up he's actually
drawing on some pretty deep ideas here
after all donnie isn't just
time-traveling he's time-traveling
across parallel universes which based on
your choice
philosophers and physicists is possible
physicist Hugh Everett for example was
famous for coining the idea of a
multiverse as a way to explain
wavefunction collapse in quantum
mechanics in quantum mechanics before
being observed a particle exists in a
superposition of states for instance a
photon acts like both a particle and a
wave until you try to look at it and
then it makes up its mind about being
either one
the act of observance somehow forces
this indefinite state to collapse into a
definite state how well there's no real
answer right now but Everett theorized
that these collapses don't really exist
at all instead when we observe a
particle we're observing a symptom of
the universe splitting as both states
are realized in different realities what
this means for us is that there are
nearly infinite branching realities
running alongside our own so does that
mean a universe could exist that was
cosmically doomed such as Kellie's
tangent universe well likely not unlike
media's newfound obsession with
multiverses this fog is your universe
soggy it's weird it's gross and this
delicious normal fry is my universe
Everett's theory of the multiple worlds
doesn't invalidate the basic laws of
physics parallel universes aren't going
to collapse into each other but that
doesn't necessarily rule out Donny's
time-travel adventures how is that
possible
how is time travel possible now I know
that might sound weird to say that time
travel is possible but it lies in the
film's very specific depiction of the
idea maybe some of you have heard of the
grandfather paradox which states that
backwards time travel is impossible
because then you could kill your
grandfather and then you wouldn't exist
so who goes back in time and kills your
grandfather by invoking parallel
universes Kelly completely sidesteps
this logical problem killing your
grandfather would just make a parallel
universe where you don't exist like the
grandfather paradox
how could a bullet hold Frank be able to
warn Donnie about the world ending if
Donnie went back in time and saved it
well if Frank was from a parallel
universe then it all checks out and if
you think we're reaching here to explain
away some inconsistencies in the film I
don't think so remember those world
lines we talked about earlier physicist
Kurt girdle proved that a universe could
hypothetically exist in which these
world lines were actually closed loops
that means by going forward in time you
could end up in your own past kind of
like your future self flapping your past
self in Mario Cart and while our
particular universe is not constructed
this way
various physicists have proposed how
these closed timelike curves could
theoretically exist like physicists John
Wheeler and GIP Thorne who believe these
mario kart track timelines could be
generated using wormholes and again
donnie darko does throw this idea out
there according to Hawking a wormhole
may be able to provide a shortcut for
jumping between two distant regions of
space-time but while the movie alludes
to all these weighty ideas in the end
everything comes back to Kelly's weird
mythos sure Donnie and his teacher talk
about science but then Kelly explains
everything away like this in the
director's cut water and metal are the
key elements of time travel
water is the barrier element for the
construction of time portals used as
gateways between universes at the
tangent vortex so no science no real
discernible philosophy or belief system
just Kelly's unique brand of mysticism
and yeah certainly not enough to really
flesh out a philosophy of video idea 3
the birth
so here's the big question wisecrack why
is this film such a cultural milestone
why do people point to it as a really
profound movie while I can point to a
lot of things like the great cast and
amazing soundtrack for me it comes down
to how well Donnie Darko functions as an
exploration of upper-middle-class eggs
from its depiction of teenage sexual
frustration to baby boomers struggling
to understand their child's mental
illness the film is an incredible
exploration of growing up privileged in
the late 80s if any of you have ever
lived in suburbia you know how
frustratingly appearance focused it can
be take mrs. farmer for example a parent
and teacher who's obsessed with her own
moral crusade I want to know why this
film is being taught to our children
throughout the film we see mrs. farmer
constantly judge and belittle others for
not subscribing to Jim Cunningham's BS
self-help advice especially Donnie's
more liberal mother our pass through
life must be righteous I urge you to go
home and look in the mirror and pray
that your son doesn't succumb to the
path of fear of course mrs. farmer is
never concerned about being truly moral
despite her idol Jim Cunningham becoming
a convicted pedophile mrs. farmer still
holds onto her steadfast belief in his
moral system proving how righteous she
really is mrs. farmer insists on going
to Jim's trial instead of taking her own
daughter to a televised talent show and
then shamelessly guilt trips Donnie's
mother Rose rose I have to appear at his
arraignment tomorrow morning and as you
know the girls are scheduled to leave
for Los Angeles in the morning now as
their coach I was the obvious choice to
chaperone them on their trip but right
now you can't go and this is where the
film really succeeds it shows us in
stunning detail all the annoying
trappings of middle-class suburban life
and then gives us a voice in Donnie to
speak out against it after all there's
something viscerally relatable to Donnie
standing up to all the ridiculous
expectations placed on him we've all
wanted to stand up and say no like
Donnie did when he rejected Jim
Cunningham's ridiculous system you can't
just lump everything into these two
categories and then just deny everything
else and to that end Donnie's acts of
rebellion and even too
struction fuel kind of acceptable he
floods the school sure but that's the
same school that fired his favorite
teacher for daring them to think for
themselves I don't think that you have a
clue what it's like to communicate with
these kids
and we are losing them to apathy to this
prescribe nonsense he burns down a house
but hey the owner was our Afra mentioned
pederast eight-year-old in the end these
acts of rebellion function as a form of
escapism to us the viewers as Freud once
paraphrased his fellow psychologist
Theodore Fontaine people cannot subsist
on the scanty satisfaction they can
extort from reality
we simply cannot do without auxilary
constructions in other words fantasy and
wish fulfillment are necessary to keep
us happy and functioning and to that end
Richard Kelly's weirdworld building
complete with superpowers and time
travel acts as the ultimate form of
escapism from suburban monogamy what if
like Donnie you actually were the center
of a tangent universe and it was up to
you to save it for me those thoughts
would at least make all those white
picket fences a little more bearable so
what do you think wisecrack did you
spend the last few years missing an
obvious angle on Donnie Darko is there a
more philosophically deep and consistent
thesis that we've missed
or are you an AR camp and think that
what makes the film so great is how it
channels our middle-class edge Lord X
javis line in the comments section and
if you want to build your own website
for free check out Wix comm slash
wisecrack peace guys
[Music]